- Witaj ponownie w kursie
Zrozumieć Informację i Obliczenia Kwantowe.
Nazywam się John Watrous i jestem
Dyrektorem Technicznym ds. Edukacji Kwantowej IBM.
To jest czwarta lekcja serii i ostatnia
lekcja w pierwszej jednostce serii poświęconej podstawom
informacji kwantowej.
Do tej pory rozmawialiśmy o tym,
jak działa informacja kwantowa zarówno dla pojedynczych, jak i wielokrotnych układów, oraz przyjrzeliśmy się modelowi
quantum circuit,
i zaobserwowaliśmy pewne
fundamentalne ograniczenia informacji kwantowej.
Po drodze napotkaliśmy ważne pojęcia matematyczne,
w tym iloczyny tensorowe i iloczyny skalarne, i będziemy kontynuować
korzystanie z tych pojęć i będziemy wprowadzać nowe,
w miarę jak będziemy ich potrzebować.
W tej lekcji skupimy się na trzech fundamentalnych i ważnych przykładach: teleportacji kwantowej, kodowaniu supergęstym i grze CHSH,
która jest też nazywana nierównością CHSH i nie zawsze opisywana jako gra.
To nie są przypadkowe przykłady mające zilustrować, jak działa informacja kwantowa — są to naprawdę kluczowe
elementy fundamentów
informacji kwantowej
i pojawiają się w różnych, a niekiedy nieoczekiwanych kontekstach w obrębie informacji kwantowej
i obliczeń.
Splątanie odgrywa kluczową rolę we wszystkich trzech tych przykładach — i to właśnie splątanie sprawia, że działają
i są interesujące. Zatem ta lekcja będzie w pewnym sensie naszą pierwszą okazją, by
zobaczyć splątanie w działaniu
i zacząć zgłębiać, co sprawia, że splątanie jest tak interesujące.
Przegląd lekcji jest bardzo prosty — omówimy po kolei
trzy wspomniane przykłady:
teleportację kwantową,
kodowanie supergęste i grę CHSH.
Omówimy, czym są te zagadnienia i co czyni je interesującymi, oraz przeprowadzimy analizy dokładnie wyjaśniające, jak działają
na poziomie matematycznym.
Zanim przejdziemy do pierwszego
z trzech przykładów, czyli teleportacji kwantowej, warto najpierw
przedstawić bohaterów:
Alice i Boba, na wypadek gdybyś
ich nie znał.
Alice i Bob to imiona
nadawane hipotetycznym bytom lub agentom w układach, protokołach, grach
i w zasadzie każdym innym rodzaju interakcji, który można rozważyć, a który wiąże się z wymianą informacji.
Po raz pierwszy pojawiły się
w kontekście kryptografii w latach 70. XX wieku, lecz konwencja używania tych imion w ten sposób stała się bardzo powszechna
w znacznie szerszym kontekście od tamtej pory. Chodzi o to, że są to bardzo popularne imiona, przynajmniej w niektórych częściach świata, i zaczynają się na litery A i B,
a dodatkowo wygodnie jest
odnosić się do Alice i Boba za pomocą zaimków „ona" i „on", dla zwięzłości.
Zwykle wyobrażamy sobie, że Alice i Bob znajdują się w różnych miejscach i mają różne
cele oraz różne zachowania
w zależności od tego, o czym rozmawiamy.
Na przykład jeśli mówimy
o komunikacji, czyli transmisji informacji, możemy postanowić,
że Alice jest nadawcą
a Bob odbiorcą
przekazywanej informacji.
Czasami Alice i Bob
współpracują — to jest bardzo typowe — ale czasami rywalizują lub mogą mieć różne cele, które mogą lub nie mogą być ze sobą spójne
— to wszystko musi być jasno określone w danej sytuacji.
Oczywiście reprezentują oni abstrakcje, a niekoniecznie prawdziwych ludzi.
Możemy też wprowadzać
dodatkowe postacie, takie jak Charlie i
Diane, lub inne imiona reprezentujące różne
role, na przykład Eve
jako podsłuchiwacza lub Mallory dla kogoś zachowującego się złośliwie,
w zależności od kontekstu.
W każdym razie spotkamy Alice i Boba we wszystkich trzech
przykładach, które omówimy w tej lekcji, i od czasu do czasu
przez resztę serii. Chciałbym też poczynić kilka
uwag na temat splątania, zanim przejdę do trzech przykładów.
W lekcji drugiej napotkaliśmy ten przykład splątanego stanu dwóch qubitów.
Jest to jeden z czterech stanów Bella i można powiedzieć, że
ten konkretny stan jest archetypicznym przykładem
splątanego stanu kwantowego.
Napotkaliśmy też ten
przykład probabilistycznego stanu dwóch bitów.
Jest on w pewnym sensie analogiczny do
stanu splątanego, ale nie jest splątany —
splątanie jest zjawiskiem unikalnie
kwantowym,
zasadniczo z definicji.
Istnieje precyzyjna matematyczna definicja splątania i to, co ta definicja
zasadniczo mówi, to że splątanie
jest nieklasyczną korelacją kwantową.
Ale to nie jest zbyt
pomocne na poziomie intuicyjnym — to definicja splątania w kategoriach tego, czym splątanie nie jest,
i prawdopodobnie właśnie dlatego
dość trudno wyjaśnić, czym splątanie jest i co czyni je wyjątkowym
w kategoriach intuicyjnych.
Kiedy ludzie próbują
wyjaśnić, czym jest splątanie w kategoriach intuicyjnych, często słychać wyjaśnienia, które naprawdę nie odróżniają tych dwóch stanów
w znaczący sposób. Można usłyszeć pomysł,
że jeśli zmierzysz jeden z dwóch splątanych qubitów,
to stan drugiego
WEBVTT
zostaje w jakiś sposób natychmiastowo zmieniony, lub że stanu dwóch qubitów nie można opisać osobno
albo że dwa qubity
w jakiś sposób przechowują pamięć o sobie nawzajem, a nawet że
są emocjonalnie ze sobą związane.
Ale dlaczego te właściwości
nie dotyczą tego stanu?
Te dwa bity są ze sobą ściśle powiązane — każdy dosłownie przechowuje doskonałą pamięć o drugim — ale
to nie jest stan splątany.
Cóż, jednym ze sposobów wyjaśnienia, co sprawia, że splątanie jest wyjątkowe i co różni ten stan
bardzo od tamtego, jest wyjaśnienie, co możemy zrobić ze splątaniem
lub co możemy obserwować jako efekt splątania, co wykracza poza wybory, jakich dokonujemy, reprezentując naszą
wiedzę za pomocą wektorów.
Wszystkie trzy przykłady,
które omówimy w tej lekcji, mają tę naturę w tym sensie, że ilustrują
rzeczy, które możemy zrobić ze splątaniem, a których nie możemy zrobić z tym stanem
ani z żadnym stanem klasycznie skolerowanym.
Rzeczywiście, bardzo typowe w badaniach nad informacją kwantową i obliczeniami jest traktowanie splątania jako zasobu
za pomocą którego można
realizować różne zadania.
I kiedy tak robimy, traktujemy ten stan jako reprezentujący
jedną jednostkę splątania.
Tę jednostkę splątania
nazywamy e-bitem; „e" oznacza
„entangled" (splątany) lub „entanglement" (splątanie).
Prawda jest, że to dwa qubity, ale jako miara
splątania, to jeden e-bit.
Możesz też traktować parę
zwykłych klasycznych bitów w skorelowanym
probabilistycznym stanie z poprzedniego przykładu jako zasób, którym jest
jeden bit wspólnej losowości.
Może to być bardzo przydatne
w kryptografii — dzielić losowy bit z kimś, zakładając,
że nikt inny nie zna tego bitu, by można go było
użyć jako klucza prywatnego
lub jako części klucza prywatnego, na przykład w celu szyfrowania.
Ale w tej lekcji skupimy się na tym splątanym stanie i
tym, co możemy z nim zrobić.
Żeby doprecyzować terminologię: kiedy mówimy, że Alice
i Bob dzielą e-bit, mamy na myśli, że
Alice ma qubit o nazwie A,
Bob ma qubit o nazwie B, i razem para A, B
jest w stanie Phi plus.
Oczywiście nie jest ważne, jakie nazwy
nadamy dwóm qubitom — moglibyśmy
wybrać inne nazwy — ale przez całą tę lekcję
będziemy trzymać się tych nazw
dla jasności. Pierwszym przykładem lekcji
jest teleportacja kwantowa,
którą odtąd będziemy nazywać
po prostu teleportacją dla zwięzłości.
Teleportacja to protokół, który pozwala nadawcy
przesyłać informację kwantową do odbiorcy używając jedynie splątania
i klasycznej komunikacji
do realizacji tej transmisji.
Nie ma to absolutnie nic wspólnego z typową interpretacją
słowa „teleportacja" w science fiction, w której
materia znika
w jednym miejscu i pojawia się w innym.
Teleportacja kwantowa to po prostu nazwa, która ma przywoływać ten obraz lub metaforę, niejako.
To, co jest teleportowane, to
informacja kwantowa, a nie materia — i dzieje się to
przez transmisję klasycznej informacji
wraz ze splątaniem.
Żeby dokładnie zrozumieć,
jak działa teleportacja, pomocne jest najpierw
przygotowanie gruntu, że tak powiem.
Wyobrazimy sobie scenariusz z udziałem Alice i Boba,
a scenariusz jest następujący:
Alice ma qubit o nazwie Q, który
chciałaby przekazać Bobowi, co oznacza, że chce, aby Bob trzymał w swoich rękach
qubit będący dokładnie
w tym samym stanie, w którym jest Q w momencie rozpoczęcia protokołu.
Innymi słowy, mówimy o podstawowym problemie
transmisji informacji lub komunikacji.
Mamy nadawcę o imieniu Alice
i odbiorcę o imieniu Bob, a Alice chce wysłać
informację kwantową w postaci qubit do Boba.
Jest jednak pewne ograniczenie: Alice nie jest
w stanie fizycznie wysłać Q do Boba — wszystko, co może zrobić, to wysłać Bobowi informację klasyczną.
Alice i Bob mają też
dodatkowy zasób: dzielą e-bit.
To jest ten scenariusz — łatwo wyobrazić sobie sytuacje, w których ograniczenie, że
Alice nie może fizycznie wysłać Q
do Boba, jest rozsądną abstrakcją.
Gdyby Alice i Bob znajdowali się
na różnych kontynentach, albo gdyby Alice nie znała
dokładnej lokalizacji Boba, fizyczne wysłanie qubit
byłoby prawdopodobnie dość trudne.
Ale komunikacja klasyczna
jest oczywiście nie tylko możliwa, lecz całkiem tania
w takich okolicznościach.
Można by zapytać, czy Alice i Bob mogą wykonać to zadanie bez potrzeby posiadania wspólnego e-bitu.
Innymi słowy: czy da się
przesłać qubit używając jedynie
komunikacji klasycznej?
Odpowiedź brzmi: nie — nie jest możliwe przesłanie informacji kwantowej przy użyciu samej komunikacji klasycznej, i nie jest to zbyt trudne do udowodnienia
przy użyciu podstawowej
teorii informacji kwantowej, którą zobaczymy w
trzeciej jednostce serii.
Na razie intuicyjnym
sposobem myślenia o tym jest twierdzenie o zakazie klonowania.
WEBVTT
Wyobraź sobie, że istnieje sposób
na przesyłanie informacji kwantowej przy użyciu samej komunikacji klasycznej,
ale klasyczna komunikacja
może być łatwo kopiowana i rozgłaszana, co oznacza,
że komunikacja klasyczna
mogłaby być rozgłoszona do dwóch
odbiorców — powiedzmy Boba i Charlie'ego.
Gdyby oboje otrzymali
tę samą informację klasyczną od Alice, czy oboje
mieliby w końcu Q?
Sugerowałoby to, że sklonowaliśmy Q — ale wiemy, że to niemożliwe.
Na marginesie, warto
zauważyć, że oczywiście możliwe jest opisanie
wektorów stanów kwantowych przy użyciu informacji klasycznej.
Każdy wektor stanu kwantowego,
który zobaczysz w tej serii, jest ci opisywany
przy użyciu informacji klasycznej, która została przesłana do urządzenia,
na którym to oglądasz.
Ogólnie możemy sobie wyobrazić
opisywanie, w jakim stanie jest Q, przy użyciu klasycznych bitów,
być może z pewną dokładnością,
ale to nie jest komunikacja kwantowa — to tylko opisywanie
stanów kwantowych jako wektorów, i wrócimy do
rozróżnienia między nimi
za chwilę.
Wracając jednak do scenariusza i pracując pod
założeniem, że Alice i Bob rzeczywiście dzielą e-bit, zobaczymy, że Alice i Bob
mają wszystko, czego potrzebują
do wykonania zadania, i właśnie to robi protokół teleportacji kwantowej, używając konkretnie dwóch bitów
komunikacji klasycznej.
Zanim jednak przejdziemy do
szczegółów, pozwól, że poczynię kilka szybkich
uwag, aby upewnić się, że założenia są jasne.
Po pierwsze, zakładamy
tutaj, że stan Q jest nieznany Alice i
Bobowi, więc w szczególności
Alice nie może wysłać Bobowi
opisu stanu Q, bo go ogólnie nie zna.
Musimy też uwzględnić możliwość, że Q jest skolerowany z innymi układami, w tym możliwość,
że jest splątany
z innymi układami, i
transmisja tego qubit do Boba musi zachować te korelacje.
Wreszcie wspomniałem
o twierdzeniu o zakazie klonowania, kiedy mówiłem o
próbie klasycznego przekazywania qubitów, ale
jest tu jeszcze jedno powiązanie
z twierdzeniem o zakazie klonowania, a mianowicie takie, że jeśli Bob
otrzyma transmisję tego qubit Q od Alice,
to Alice nie może go już mieć,
ponieważ Q nie może być sklonowany — i to jest coś, o czym warto pamiętać
rozważając protokół teleportacji.
Protokół teleportacji
można opisać w dość prosty i bezpośredni sposób za pomocą diagramu quantum circuit, jak widać tutaj.
Jest nieco stylizowany w tym sensie,
że przedstawia rozdzielenie między częścią Alice i częścią Boba, ale poza tym jest to po prostu
diagram quantum circuit,
wszystko powyżej przerywanej linii
reprezentuje działania Alice, a wszystko poniżej
reprezentuje działania Boba.
Czas płynie od lewej do prawej jak zawsze i widzimy, że zaczynamy
od tych dwóch qubitów będących w stanie Phi plus —
to jest e-bit,
od którego zaczynają Alice i Bob.
Możemy oznaczyć qubity, by było jasne, który jest który: to jest qubit A, a to jest qubit
B tworzące e-bit,
a to jest qubit Q, który
Alice chce przekazać Bobowi.
Tutaj zakładamy, że
stan tego qubit Q jest Psi, ale nieco później przyjrzymy się możliwości,
że Q jest splątany
z jakimś innym układem. A to, co diagram twierdzi, ponieważ napisaliśmy psi na dole,
jest to, że ten circuit
faktycznie transmituje jakikolwiek stan psi, który mieliśmy
tutaj na górze u Alice, tutaj na dole do części Boba —
jedyna komunikacja
przechodząca przez
linię między Alice a Bobem to dwa klasyczne
bity reprezentowane przez te podwójne linie tutaj.
Zmniejszmy nieco ten
diagram, żebyśmy mieli trochę więcej miejsca, i przyjrzyjmy się
circuitowi bliżej.
Już opisałem
warunki początkowe, ale żeby podsumować: Alice trzyma qubit A,
a Bob trzyma qubit B,
gdzie A i B razem
są w stanie Phi plus — to właśnie oznacza dzielenie e-bitu.
Alice ma też qubit Q, który chce przekazać Bobowi, i rozważamy przypadek, w którym Q jest w pewnym dowolnym stanie kwantowym Psi.
Nie wiemy nic
o tym, jak Alice i Bob weszli w posiadanie tego e-bitu.
Być może mają go
od dawna — może stworzyli go jakiś czas temu, gdy byli w tym samym miejscu
i przechowywali go
na tę okazję — ale te szczegóły nie są tu istotne.
Kolejne kroki, które stanowią
sam protokół teleportacji, są następujące — i żeby było jasne,
to są kroki,
które opisuje diagram, i właśnie zamierzamy
zapisać je słowami, żeby było jasne, co
diagram wyraża.
Alice najpierw wykonuje
operację controlled-NOT, gdzie qubit Q, który
chce wysłać do Boba, jest kontrolerem, a
qubit A jest celem.
Następnym krokiem jest wykonanie
przez nią operacji Hadamard na Q, a następnie pomierzenie
dwóch qubitów, które trzyma,
A i Q, względem standardowych pomiarów bazowych, i niech mała litera a będzie wynikiem pomiaru qubit A,
WEBVTT
a mała litera b będzie wynikiem pomiaru qubit Q.
Alice następnie wysyła te
dwa klasyczne bity do Boba — to jedyna komunikacja zaangażowana w tym protokole, co jest zaznaczone w diagramie
przez to, że te dwa
bity przekraczają przerywaną linię między Alice a Bobem,
którą można traktować jako reprezentującą
jakikolwiek dystans dzielący ich.
Po odebraniu bitów
a i b Bob robi dwie rzeczy.
Po pierwsze, jeśli a jest równe jeden, wykonuje operację X, czyli innymi słowy, bramkę NOT na swoim qubit B,
a w przeciwnym razie, gdy a jest równe zero, tego nie robi.
I analogicznie,
jeśli b jest równe jeden, Bob wykonuje operację Z,
czyli bramkę Z, czyli odwrócenie fazy,
również na qubit b — i jak
poprzednio, jeśli b jest równe zero, tego nie robi.
Wszystko to jest zaznaczone na rysunku, gdzie mamy te bramki controlled-X
i controlled-Z, gdzie kontrolerami są
dwa klasyczne bity.
Nie musisz myśleć o tych bramkach jako bramkach kontrolowanych,
jeśli nie chcesz — to tylko wygodny sposób
wyrażenia tego, czego chcemy
w formie diagramu circuit. Chodzi o to, że Bob stosuje
bramkę X do qubit b, jeśli a jest równe jeden, a następnie stosuje bramkę Z
do qubit b, jeśli B jest równe jeden.
Dla wygody możemy zapisać wprost
łączną operację, którą Bob wykonuje na swoim qubit b,
w zależności od klasycznych
bitów, które wysyła Alice.
Taki jest protokół teleportacji — całkiem prosty, naprawdę. To, że faktycznie działa, to inna kwestia, i choć analiza
nie jest aż tak skomplikowana,
nie powinieneś czuć, że czegoś ci brakuje, jeśli od razu nie widzisz, dlaczego to działa.
Dlatego właśnie musimy
przeprowadzić analizę i właśnie to zrobimy teraz.
Aby przeanalizować protokół teleportacji, przejdziemy przez niego krok po kroku, żeby zobaczyć, jakie są stany trzech qubitów w różnych momentach czasu.
Najpierw rozważymy
przypadek, w którym górny qubit jest w stanie alfa zero plus beta jeden, gdzie alfa i beta
są dowolnymi liczbami zespolonymi
powodującymi, że ten wektor
jest wektorem jednostkowym.
To jest qubit Q, który
Alice stara się transmitować, ale w tej chwili nie obchodzi nas tak naprawdę, jak się nazywa.
Nieco później przyjrzymy się
sytuacji, w której ten qubit jest
splątany z innym układem, ale to jest dobry punkt startowy, by rzeczy były proste
i by nieco wyraźniej zobaczyć, jak działa analiza.
Jeśli rozważymy stan
trzech qubitów razem na początku, widzimy,
że ten stan ma postać, którą widzisz tutaj.
Dwa pierwsze qubity są
w stanie Phi plus, trzeci qubit jest tym górnym
zgodnie z konwencją
dotyczącą porządkowania qubitów, którą
opisałem w poprzedniej lekcji, więc bierzemy iloczyn tensorowy, aby uzyskać stan
trzech qubitów razem.
Możemy rozwinąć to wyrażenie,
najpierw podstawiając definicję stanu Phi plus, a następnie obliczając iloczyn tensorowy
i otrzymujemy stan,
który widzisz tutaj.
Przy okazji, nie zawsze jest najlepszą
strategią całkowite rozwinięcie
wektora w ten sposób — generalnie dobrym pomysłem jest poczekanie, aż
mamy dobry powód, by to zrobić.
Ale tutaj mamy powód: chcielibyśmy
obliczyć działanie tej bramki controlled NOT — zapisując stan w tej formie,
możemy bardzo łatwo to zrobić.
I w szczególności jest to
stan trzech qubitów po zastosowaniu bramki controlled NOT.
Trzeci qubit jest qubit kontrolującym, ponieważ zgodnie z naszą konwencją jest on
na górze, a drugi qubit,
czyli środkowy,
jest celem, więc po prostu
działamy na kety odpowiednio: jeśli trzeci bit wynosi
zero, nic się nie dzieje,
a jeśli trzeci bit wynosi jeden,
odwracamy drugi bit.
Następnie wykonujemy bramkę Hadamard
na trzecim qubit — możemy zapisać wynikowy
wektor jak widać
tutaj, podstawiając
stan plus i stan minus za stan zero i stan jeden.
Jeśli chcemy mieć dość
miejsca, by rozwinąć ten jeden, trzeba będzie go trochę zmniejszyć — teraz, podstawiając stany
plus i minus
przez ich definicje
i przenosząc pierwiastek z dwóch do mianownika, otrzymujemy stan, który widzisz tutaj.
I rozwijając to, otrzymujemy stan, który widzisz tutaj.
Taki jest stan trzech qubitów po tym, jak Alice wykona swoje dwie operacje.
Alice następnie mierzy
i jeśli chcemy przeanalizować pomiary, to izolujemy standardowe wektory bazowe
dla mierzonych układów
tak jak omawialiśmy to w lekcji drugiej — i jeśli to zrobimy w tym konkretnym przypadku, otrzymamy to.
I jeśli przez chwilę przyjrzysz się temu wyrażeniu, może wydać się nieco osobliwe, bo teraz wygląda, jakby pierwszy qubit,
czyli dolny qubit,
zależał w jakiś sposób od alfa i beta, choć
w tym momencie nie było żadnej komunikacji przez przerywaną linię,
WEBVTT
ale to tylko złudzenie. Pamiętaj, że skalary swobodnie przechodzą przez iloczyny tensorowe, więc tak naprawdę nie ma sensu,
w którym alfa i beta
byłyby powiązane z pierwszym qubit.
Tak naprawdę jedyne, co zrobiliśmy,
to użyliśmy nawiasów zgodnie z
wieloliniowością iloczynów tensorowych.
W każdym razie to jest forma, którą musimy mieć, by zobaczyć, co robi pomiar — i możemy od razu zauważyć
jedną interesującą rzecz:
prawdopodobieństwa czterech możliwych wyników pomiaru są zawsze jednorodne.
Prawdopodobieństwo zmierzenia każdej
pary wyników wynosi jedną czwartą, więc w szczególności
nie ma żadnej zależności
od alfa i beta.
Widzimy to w każdym przypadku, obliczając kwadrat normy euklidesowej
wektora połączonego iloczynem tensorowym ze standardowym wektorem bazowym, który wyizolowaliśmy,
i w każdym przypadku mamy jedną czwartą, którą otrzymujemy, kwadratując jedną drugą razy kwadrat wartości bezwzględnej alfa
plus kwadrat wartości
bezwzględnej beta, co jest równe jeden — więc dostajemy jedną czwartą w każdym przypadku.
Jest to wręcz bardzo ważne,
że prawdopodobieństwa tych różnych wyników nie zależą w żaden sposób od qubit, który
Alice chce transmitować.
Nie moglibyśmy mieć sytuacji, w której dowolny stan wchodzi tutaj i wychodzi tam, a jednocześnie pomiar ujawniłby
informację o tym stanie.
Jeśli chcesz uzyskać informację o dowolnym stanie kwantowym, będziesz musiał zaburzyć
ten stan ogólnie rzecz biorąc.
Oto tabela opisująca nie tylko prawdopodobieństwa
różnych wyników, ale też stan
trzech qubitów razem
warunkowy na każdy możliwy
wynik pomiaru.
Otrzymujemy to, normalizując wektory połączone iloczynem tensorowym z różnymi
standardowymi stanami bazowymi, ale w tym przypadku jest to proste —
po prostu eliminujemy czynnik jednej drugiej, aby otrzymać wektor jednostkowy.
Zatem to, co mamy bezpośrednio
po pomiarze Alice, to że Alice ma dwa równomiernie losowe bity i nic więcej.
W szczególności nie ma już
oryginalnego stanu i nie ma żadnej
informacji o nim — ma tylko losowe bity.
Stan Boba teraz
zależy od alfa i beta, a także od wyników pomiaru.
Gdybyśmy na chwilę założyli,
że Alice jeszcze nie wysłała wyników pomiaru,
tak że Bob nie wie, jakie są wyniki pomiaru,
to nie byłby w stanie
uzyskać żadnej informacji o alfa i beta
mierząc swój qubit.
Te cztery możliwości,
które mamy tutaj, są wystarczająco pomieszane, by zapewnić, że żadna informacja
o alfa i beta
nie mogłaby być uzyskana
przez pomiar. To musi być prawdą na poziomie intuicyjnym, bo inaczej mielibyśmy
komunikację szybszą niż światło.
Alice z pewnością nie może
przekazywać informacji Bobowi bez wysyłania czegokolwiek, ale oczywiście Alice wysyła wyniki pomiaru
do Boba — więc rozszerzmy tabelę, by zobaczyć, co się dzieje, gdy
Bob wykonuje swoje operacje.
W tej kolumnie tutaj mamy różne operacje, które Bob faktycznie wykonuje dla każdego z możliwych
wyników pomiarów
jak obserwowaliśmy wcześniej,
i jeśli przejdziemy po kolei i zastosujemy tę
operację do qubit Boba, który jest pierwszym, B,
widzimy, że we wszystkich czterech przypadkach otrzymujemy ten sam
wynik — i tym wynikiem jest oryginalny stan.
Oryginalny stan qubit Q został pomyślnie steleportowany do B.
Jeśli Bob chce przemianować swój qubit i nazwać go Q w tym momencie, jest jak najbardziej mile widziany, ale chodzi o to, że teraz
trzyma oryginalny stan,
który miała Alice — i oczywiście z konieczności Alice nie ma go już.
Zauważ też, że e-bit
został niejako „spalony" przez ten proces —
teleportacja ma koszt,
a kosztem jest jeden e-bit i dwa klasyczne bity komunikacji — i gdy protokół jest
skończony, e-bit znika.
Ustaliliśmy teraz, że
protokół teleportacji działa poprawnie przy założeniu, że górny qubit jest w stanie kwantowym
postaci alfa razy ket
zero plus beta razy ket jeden.
Ale co się dzieje, gdy górny qubit jest splątany z jakimś innym układem, takim jak
jeden z naszych dodatkowych qubitów
jak mamy tutaj na ekranie? Możemy chcieć użyć teleportacji
w takich okolicznościach.
Może Alice i Bob faktycznie
planują wykonać teleportację 100 razy, tak żeby Alice mogła transmitować
jakiś 100-qubitowy rejestr kwantowy
do Boba, jeden qubit na raz.
Albo może te dodatkowe
qubity wcale nie są w posiadaniu Alice
i ktoś inny je ma — może Alice nawet
nie wie, że istnieją.
Pytanie brzmi: czy
teleportacja nadal działa, nawet jeśli teleportowany qubit jest splątany z innym układem?
Tutaj stan qubit Q razem z dodatkowym
układem, który rozważamy, jest wyrażony jak widać tutaj na górze
gdzie gamma zero i
gamma jeden są wektorami jednostkowymi reprezentującymi stany kwantowe
tego dodatkowego układu.
Zawsze możemy zapisać dowolny stan układu złożonego w ten sposób.
Właściwie nie potrzebujemy
nawet alfa i beta, ale jeśli je uwzględnimy,
to możemy przyjąć, że gamma zero i gamma jeden są wektorami jednostkowymi
i sprawi to, że
powiązanie z prostszym przypadkiem, który już rozważaliśmy, będzie bardziej przejrzyste.
WEBVTT
Możemy przeprowadzić
podobną analizę do tej, którą już przeprowadziliśmy, ale gdzie śledzimy też
ten dodatkowy układ.
Jest nieco bardziej zawiła, bo mamy dodatkowy układ, ale
idea jest dokładnie ta sama — oto bardzo skrótowe podsumowanie.
To jest stan początkowy, to jest stan po
bramce controlled NOT,
a to jest stan po
operacji Hadamard.
Jeśli rozwijamy te wyrażenia,
możemy wyrazić ten stan jak widać tutaj,
to jest stan bezpośrednio
przed pomiarami Alice — i jeśli przejdziemy przez
możliwości tak jak poprzednio
i rozważymy, co
się dzieje, gdy Bob stosuje jakąkolwiek operację, którą ma zastosować,
to stwierdzimy, że rzeczywiście
wychodzi poprawny stan i protokół działa zgodnie z oczekiwaniami.
W tej tabeli przy okazji używamy litery R do
odniesienia się do tego dodatkowego układu — i widzisz, że stosujemy dość prosty trik:
decydujemy, że wolimy, przynajmniej chwilowo, uporządkować
układy jako B, R, A, Q,
bo to jest wygodniejsze dla zapisywania stanów tutaj.
Zgodnie z diagramem układy powinny być
uporządkowane jako B, A, Q, R,
ale dopóki to jasno zaznaczymy, możemy wybrać inne
porządkowanie, które jest wygodniejsze.
W skrócie, wszystko, co się dzieje w tej analizie, jest
tym samym, co w prostszej analizie,
tylko że mamy
te dodatkowe wektory, gamma zero i gamma jeden,
które jak gdyby jadą na gapę.
Zawsze mamy gamma zero,
gdy jest czynnik alfa, i gamma jeden, gdy
jest czynnik beta — i na koniec dnia
wszystko wychodzi poprawnie.
To w ogóle nie jest zaskakujące — mamy proces fizyczny, który działa jak operacja identyczności na qubit
w dowolnym stanie kwantowym, i jest tylko jeden
sposób, żeby tak się stało — a mianowicie, że ta operacja
jest operacją identyczności.
To jest nieco łatwiejsze do wyjaśnienia przy użyciu ogólnego sformułowania
informacji kwantowej, ale chodzi o to, że przez liniowość
tak naprawdę nie musieliśmy przeprowadzać tej dodatkowej analizy.
Gdy wiemy, że
teleportacja działa poprawnie dla jednego qubit w izolacji, możemy stwierdzić, że jest tylko jedna możliwa rzecz,
która może opisywać, co robi protokół — a mianowicie to, że implementuje
operację identyczności, gdzie qubit wchodzi tutaj
i wychodzi tutaj, działając efektywnie jak doskonały
bezszumowy kanał kwantowy.
Kilka szybkich uwag
na temat teleportacji, zanim przejdziemy do
drugiego przykładu lekcji, jakim jest kodowanie supergęste.
Po pierwsze, myślę, że ważne jest doprecyzowanie, że teleportacja nie jest zastosowaniem informacji kwantowej — to protokół
i konkretnie jest to
protokół służący do wykonywania komunikacji kwantowej.
Aby teleportacja,
jak ją opisałem, była użyteczna, musi istnieć jakiś powód do wykonywania komunikacji kwantowej.
Po drugie, można spekulować, że teleportacja mogłaby pewnego
dnia stać się standardowym sposobem
komunikowania informacji kwantowej, a konkretnie proces znany jako destylacja splątania
mógłby potencjalnie być używany
jako sposób niezawodnego przekazywania qubitów. Gdyby Alice i Bob wiedzieli, że będą się komunikować za pomocą informacji kwantowej lub mieliby potrzebę komunikowania
informacji kwantowej, to ten proces destylacji splątania
mógłby być używany do konwersji większej liczby szumowych e-bitów
na mniejszą liczbę
wysokiej jakości e-bitów, które następnie mogłyby być używane do bezszumowej lub prawie bezszumowej teleportacji.
Idea jest taka, że proces
destylacji splątania nie jest w pewnym sensie tak delikatny — można by akceptować straty i
jeśli nie wychodzi,
można po prostu spróbować jeszcze raz, podczas gdy faktyczne qubity, które
chcielibyśmy przekazać, mogłyby być uważane za znacznie cenniejsze.
Oczywiście to wszystko spekulacja, ale chodzi o to, że nie jest trudno wyobrazić sobie sytuacje, w których teleportacja
mogłaby być bardzo praktycznym
sposobem przekazywania qubitów.
I ostatnia uwaga
dotycząca teleportacji: idea stojąca za teleportacją i sposób, w jaki działa,
jest dość fundamentalna
w informacji kwantowej i obliczeniach — teleportacja jest naprawdę kamieniem węgielnym teorii informacji kwantowej, a wariacje
na ten temat często się pojawiają. To tylko jeden przykład: istnieją propozycje
implementowania różnych bramek kwantowych
przy użyciu teleportacji,
gdzie wybierane są różne stany początkowe i pomiary, tak że wynikiem
jest zastosowanie wybranej operacji
zamiast komunikacji.
Następnym przykładem jest kodowanie supergęste.
Podobnie jak teleportacja kwantowa,
kodowanie supergęste jest protokołem, a to, co osiąga, jest komplementarne do teleportacji.
Podczas gdy teleportacja pozwala
na transmisję jednego qubit przy użyciu e-bitu i dwóch
klasycznych bitów komunikacji,
kodowanie supergęste pozwala
na transmisję dwóch klasycznych bitów przy użyciu
e-bitu i jednego qubit komunikacji kwantowej.
Krótko mówiąc, kodowanie supergęste umożliwia transmisję
informacji klasycznej i właśnie dlatego nazywa się kodowaniem supergęstym,
WEBVTT
bo pozwala na spakowanie dwóch
klasycznych bitów komunikacji w jeden qubit,
ale musimy „spalić"
e-bit, żeby to osiągnąć.
Oto dokładniejsze
wyjaśnienie konfiguracji.
Znowu mamy Alice i Boba, gdzie Alice jest nadawcą
a Bob odbiorcą, i tym razem Alice ma dwa klasyczne bity,
które chce wysłać Bobowi.
Alice może wysłać Bobowi jeden qubit, a Alice i Bob dzielą
e-bit, który mogą wykorzystać, żeby wykonać swoje zadanie,
czyli żeby Bob otrzymał
dwa klasyczne bity.
Można powiedzieć, że to zadanie wydaje się mniej interesujące niż to, które realizuje
teleportacja,
szczególnie jeśli uważamy,
że wysyłanie qubitów jest znacznie
trudniejsze lub bardziej wymagające niż wysyłanie klasycznych bitów,
co jest dość rozsądnym punktem widzenia, ale zdecydowanie interesujące jest, że jest to możliwe.
Jednym z powodów, dla których jest to interesujące,
jest to, że jest faktycznie niemożliwe wykonanie
tego zadania transmitowania dwóch klasycznych bitów informacji
przy użyciu jednego qubit bez
korzystania z e-bitu.
Wiemy to ze względu na słynne twierdzenie znane jako twierdzenie Holevo.
Twierdzenie Holevo jest
ogólniejsze niż to, a dokładne sformułowanie
twierdzenia Holevo jest nieco techniczne i wymaga pewnego wyjaśnienia,
ale jedną z jego implikacji
jest to, że nie można przesłać żadnej liczby klasycznych
bitów komunikacji przy użyciu mniejszej liczby qubitów
samej komunikacji kwantowej.
Jeśli chcesz niezawodnie przesłać dwa klasyczne bity
informacji przy użyciu qubitów, a nie masz
e-bitu do wykorzystania,
będziesz musiał wysłać dwa qubity, więc równie dobrze mogą one przechowywać bity, które chcesz transmitować.
Innym powodem, dla którego kodowanie supergęste
jest interesujące, jest bliski
komplementarny związek, jaki ma z teleportacją — i do tego
wrócimy nieco później. Oto opis protokołu kodowania supergęstego w postaci quantum circuit.
Dla tego protokołu nie będę
wymieniał wszystkich kroków, lecz zamiast tego zostaniemy przy opisie diagramu circuit.
Jak widać, znowu
mamy Alice i Boba, gdzie Alice jest na górze
a Bob na dole.
Oto e-bit
początkowo dzielony między Alice i Boba, który
został jakoś ustalony przed uruchomieniem protokołu.
Alice ma dwa klasyczne bity, A i B, które widzisz tutaj
i przez protokół opisany przez circuit
te dwa klasyczne bity
trafią w ręce Boba.
Jest tylko jeden qubit
przekraczający linię między Alice a Bobem — i oczywiście nie są
wysyłane żadne klasyczne bity,
to transmisja
dwóch klasycznych bitów jest celem protokołu.
Zauważysz też, że ma dokładnie
te same komponenty, które są używane w teleportacji: mamy bramkę controlled NOT,
bramkę Hadamard,
oraz bramkę Z i bramkę X
kontrolowane przez klasyczne bity.
Są jednak inaczej ułożone, więc przejdźmy do
analizy, żeby zobaczyć, jak to działa.
Żeby przeanalizować, jak działa kodowanie supergęste, zacznijmy od zapisania
bazy Bella, która leży w samym
sercu tej analizy.
Zrobimy najpierw to: przyjrzymy się efektowi, jaki działania Alice
wywierają na stan Phi plus — i zobaczymy,
że Alice transformuje ten
stan Phi plus do jednego
z czterech stanów Bella w zależności od bitów,
które chce wysłać.
Zapiszmy więc tabelę, żebyśmy mogli
śledzić, co się dzieje.
Po pierwsze, jeśli A i B są oba zero, to ani bramka Z, ani
bramka X nie jest stosowana, więc działania Alice nic nie robią —
co znaczy, że Phi
plus jest mapowane na Phi plus.
Możemy też to wyrazić jako równanie jak widać tutaj:
nic nie dzieje się z qubit Alice i nic nie dzieje się z qubit Boba
a nierobienie niczego jest reprezentowane
przez macierz identyczności.
Co się dzieje, gdy A jest równe zero, a B równe jeden?
Ponieważ B jest równe jeden, stosujemy bramkę Z i
nie stosujemy bramki X, bo A jest równe zero —
i widzimy, że ogólny efekt jest taki, że Alice wykonuje bramkę Z.
Alice jest po prawej
stronie, bo jest na górze, choć tak naprawdę
nie miałoby to żadnego znaczenia w tym konkretnym
przypadku — efektem jest
że stan Phi plus
jest mapowany na Phi minus, co można dostrzec z tych wyrażeń, jeśli pamiętasz, jak działa bramka Z.
Możemy dodać ten do naszej tabeli — są jeszcze dwa przypadki do rozważenia: jeśli A jest równe jeden
i B jest równe zero,
Alice wykonuje bramkę X,
która transformuje Phi plus w Chi plus — i jeśli A jest równe jeden
i B jest równe jeden,
Alice wykonuje Z, a następnie
X i otrzymujemy Chi minus.
Zatem nasza tabela mówi nam, co się dzieje w czterech możliwych przypadkach — Alice efektywnie wybiera, który z tych czterech
WEBVTT
stanów Bella chce dzielić z Bobem — i ma swobodę wyboru, działając tylko na swoim qubit
— to jest dość interesujący
aspekt splątania.
Alice następnie wysyła swój qubit
do Boba — w tym momencie Bob posiada jeden z czterech stanów Bella i musi tylko
ustalić, który to jest,
żeby odtworzyć bity.
I możemy sprawdzić, że
rzeczywiście bramka controlled NOT a następnie bramka Hadamard,
jak mamy w diagramie, robią właściwą rzecz.
Nie będę przez to przechodzić szczegółowo, ale jeśli to zrobisz, przekonasz się, że efekt jest
taki jak widzisz tutaj w tabeli.
Jednym ze sposobów sprawdzenia
jest po prostu obliczenie. Alternatywnie możemy rozpoznać, że właściwie
przeszliśmy przez to w odwrotnej kolejności
w poprzedniej lekcji. W poprzedniej lekcji mieliśmy najpierw bramkę Hadamard i bramkę controlled NOT jako drugą
i widzieliśmy, że ten circuit
mapował standardowe stany bazowe na stany Bella z irytującym
minusem w jednym z przypadków.
Gdy odwrócimy kolejność bramek i uwzględnimy fakt,
że obie te bramki są swoimi własnymi odwrotnościami,
otrzymujemy odwrotność —
i tak w tym
przypadku działanie idzie w odwrotnym kierunku,
a minus może wybrać, po której
stronie chce być —
ale poza tym jest tam, gdzie powinien być, i w tym momencie od razu widać, że pomiar ujawnia poprawne wartości —
minus tutaj nie przeszkadza, bo jeden pojawia się z
prawdopodobieństwem jeden w tym przypadku — i na tym polega cała analiza.
W skrócie, Alice wybiera stan Bella, a Bob ustala, który to jest.
Kilka krótkich uwag
na temat kodowania supergęstego, zanim przejdziemy dalej: po pierwsze, powinniśmy przyznać, że kodowanie supergęste
prawdopodobnie nie będzie
użyteczne ani praktyczne w żadnym sensie jako środek
transmisji informacji klasycznej.
Komunikacja klasyczna
jest bardzo tania, a fizyczne wysyłanie qubitów jest trudne, delikatnie mówiąc,
i dopóki tak jest, nie można oczekiwać żadnej
praktycznej przewagi wynikającej z kodowania supergęstego.
Ale to, że prawdopodobnie nie będzie praktyczne, nie oznacza, że kodowanie supergęste
nie jest interesujące.
Jest w rzeczywistości bardzo interesujące, gdyż leżąca u podstaw idea jest
naprawdę bardzo fundamentalna,
a kiedy mówię o leżącej u podstaw idei, mam na myśli ideę, że jeśli Alice
dzieli stan Bella z Bobem,
to może zdecydować się zmienić ten stan na dowolny inny stan Bella,
który wybierze, sama z siebie — nie potrzebuje
pomocy Boba.
To jest konkretny przykład
dotyczący stanów Bella, ale istnieje ogólniejsza idea dotycząca swobody, jaką ma jeden z graczy
przy transformacji splątanego stanu dzielonego z innym graczem — i dokładne zrozumienie, czym jest ta swoboda,
jest ważnym krokiem w rozumieniu informacji kwantowej — i zobaczymy, jak dokładnie opisać tę swobodę w prostych
i eleganckich kategoriach w
trzeciej jednostce serii.
Kodowanie supergęste daje też
konkretny przykład tego, co można zrobić ze splątaniem, a mianowicie umożliwić transmisję dwóch klasycznych
bitów
przez wysłanie jednego qubit. Jak już wspomniałem, jest to na mocy twierdzenia Holevo niemożliwe bez splątania.
Możemy też rozważyć teleportację i kodowanie supergęste razem — i widzimy, że ustanawiają one ekwiwalencję
między jednym qubit komunikacji kwantowej a dwoma bitami komunikacji klasycznej.
Dopóki jesteś gotowy
wydać jeden e-bit, możesz efektywnie
konwertować jedno na drugie.
Teleportacja pozwala na
komunikowanie jednego qubit przy użyciu dwóch klasycznych bitów komunikacji, a kodowanie supergęste działa w drugą stronę
i pozwala na transmisję dwóch klasycznych
bitów przy użyciu jednego qubit komunikacji kwantowej.
Bez wydania e-bitu jednak nie możesz transformować
żadnego z nich w drugie — to splątanie
umożliwia to.
Trzeci i ostatni przykład,
który omówimy w tej lekcji, to nie protokół, lecz
gra znana jako gra CHSH.
Kiedy mówimy o grze w tym kontekście, nie mówimy o czymś, co ma być
grane dla zabawy lub rywalizacji,
ale raczej o abstrakcji matematycznej w sensie teorii gier na przykład.
Matematyczne abstrakcje gier są bardzo powszechnie badane w
ekonomii i informatyce na przykład — i jest
całkiem dużo wartości
do znalezienia w tej abstrakcji, więc gry nie są jedynie rozrywką,
jak się okazuje,
choć myślenie o nich jest przyjemne.
W tym konkretnym przypadku mamy zasadniczo
eksperyment myślowy, który można opisać w
dość intuicyjny sposób jako grę.
Litery CHSH odnoszą się do autorów: John Clauser, Michael
Horne, Abner Shimony i Richard Holt, którzy napisali pracę z 1969 roku, gdzie ten przykład
został po raz pierwszy opisany. Faktycznie nie opisali go
jako gry — i całkiem powszechne jest odnoszenie się do tego przykładu
nie jako gry CHSH, ale
raczej jako nierówności CHSH.
Dla informatyka takiego jak ja jednak jest po prostu bardzo naturalne
opisywanie tego jako gry.
Już sugerowałem, że
matematyczne abstrakcje gier są zarówno ważne, jak i użyteczne — i istnieje wiele różnych
kategorii gier,
WEBVTT
które można rozważać. Gra CHSH jest
przykładem klasy gier zwanych grami nielokalnymi.
Oto ogólna konfiguracja
gry nielokalnej.
Mamy dwóch graczy, Alice i Boba, którzy współpracują jako drużyna — więc albo wygrywają razem,
albo przegrywają razem.
Oznacza to, że nie mają
zachęty do działania samolubnego, więc jest to zasadniczo przeciwne
skrajności do gier o sumie zerowej,
które są czysto konkurencyjne — tutaj gra jest czysto kooperacyjna.
Jest trzecia jednostka zwana sędzią.
Sędzia nie jest graczem w grze, lecz raczej prowadzi grę — i w rzeczywistości możesz myśleć o specyfikacji
konkretnej instancji
gry nielokalnej i specyfikacji sędziego jako o równoważnych.
Na Alice i Boba nałożone jest kluczowo ważne ograniczenie: gdy gra się rozpocznie, nie mogą się ze sobą komunikować.
Mogą wcześniej uzgodnić
cokolwiek strategii wybiorą, ale żadna komunikacja
nie jest dozwolona między nimi w trakcie samej gry.
Jeśli chcesz, możesz wyobrazić sobie,
że gra odbywa się w jakimś zabezpieczonym obiekcie, jakby sędzia grał
rolę detektywa
a Alice i Bob są podejrzanymi w różnych
pokojach na komisariacie — ale innym sposobem myślenia o tej konfiguracji
jest to, że Alice i Bob są
oddzieleni ogromnym dystansem i komunikacja jest zabroniona, ponieważ prędkość światła
nie pozwala na komunikację
wystarczająco szybko. Gdyby Alice próbowała wysłać wiadomość do Boba na przykład, gra skończyłaby się,
zanim Bob ją otrzyma.
Sposób działania gry nielokalnej
jest taki, że najpierw sędzia zadaje pytanie
zarówno Alice, jak i Bobowi.
Pytanie Alice jest oznaczone jako X, a pytanie Boba jako Y.
Ogólnie możesz myśleć o X i Y jako o stanach klasycznych
z jakichkolwiek stanów klasycznych, które chcesz — i w
konkretnym przypadku gry CHSH,
X i Y są bitami.
Alice i Bob muszą następnie udzielić odpowiedzi — odpowiedź Alice jest oznaczona jako A,
a odpowiedź Boba jako B,
i ponownie te odpowiedzi można traktować jako stany klasyczne ogólnie — i podobnie jak pytania,
będą bitami w grze CHSH.
W tym momencie sędzia
podejmuje decyzję — Alice i Bob albo wygrywają, albo przegrywają w zależności od tego, czy para odpowiedzi A, B
jest uznana za poprawną dla
pary pytań X, Y, które zadał sędzia — i powiem o tym nieco więcej za chwilę.
Najpierw przyjrzyjmy się
bliżej sędziemu, żeby zrozumieć, co jest potencjalnie trudne dla Alice i Boba w grze nielokalnej.
A to, co może utrudniać
grę nielokalną, to fakt, że sędzia może używać losowości do wyboru pytań X i Y.
Oznacza to, że Alice
i Bob mają niepewność — nie wiedzą z góry, jakie pytanie zostaną zapytani — i być może co ważniejsze,
nie wiedzą, jakie pytanie
otrzymał ten drugi — i ta niepewność
w połączeniu z faktem, że nie mogą się komunikować,
stanowi wyzwanie.
Jest to podobne do sytuacji, w której detektyw
przesłuchuje dwóch podejrzanych w różnych pokojach — jeśli
podejrzani nie wiedzą,
jakie pytania zadano temu drugiemu, znacznie trudniej — jeśli są winni — utrzymać spójną historię.
Wspomniałem chwilę temu, że sędzia podejmuje ustalenie,
że Alice i Bob odpowiedzieli
poprawnie lub niepoprawnie
w zależności od pytań,
które im zadano.
Zakłada się, że to
ustalenie jest dokonywane zgodnie z jakąś stałą
zasadą — i możesz rozważać dowolną zasadę, ale cokolwiek to jest,
zakłada się, że Alice
i Bob znają tę zasadę, więc przynajmniej mają jakąś szansę na poprawne odpowiedzi.
Przyjrzymy się za chwilę zasadzie gry CHSH, ale moglibyśmy
rozważyć inną zasadę i mielibyśmy inny
przykład gry nielokalnej.
Niektóre gry nielokalnych są interesujące — i w istocie niektóre są wręcz fascynujące i tajemnicze do dziś — a niektóre nie są tak interesujące,
taka jest po prostu natura modelu gry nielokalnej.
W każdym razie są to dwie różne rzeczy potrzebne do opisania sędziego: dokładnie, jak są wybierane pytania
oraz które pary odpowiedzi są poprawne dla każdej możliwej pary pytań.
Jeśli mamy opis
tych dwóch rzeczy, to mamy opis sędziego — a to efektywnie opisuje
instancję gry nielokalnej.
Przyjrzyjmy się teraz
grze CHSH konkretnie.
Sposób, w jaki gra jest
zdefiniowana — lub równoważnie, jak sędzia jest zdefiniowany — jest następujący:
Po pierwsze, jak już wspomniałem, pytania i odpowiedzi są bitami, więc sędzia wysyła bit X
do Alice i bit Y do Boba,
a każde z nich odpowiada bitem. Alice odpowiada A
a Bob odpowiada B.
Sposób, w jaki sędzia wybiera,
jakie pytania zadać, jest prosty — wybiera je
równomiernie losowo,
więc para pytań X, Y jest jednakowo prawdopodobna jako którąkolwiek
z czterech możliwości: zero, zero, zero, jeden,
jeden, zero i jeden, jeden.
Wreszcie zasada, która
determinuje, które odpowiedzi wygrywają, a które przegrywają, jest taka, że para odpowiedzi A, B jest poprawna dla pary pytań X, Y
WEBVTT
wtedy i tylko wtedy, gdy suma modulo 2 A i B jest równa iloczynowi logicznemu X i Y.
Może być to nieco łatwiejsze do przyswojenia, jeśli wyrazimy te warunki
w formie tabeli, jak widzisz tutaj.
W pierwszej kolumnie mamy cztery możliwe pary pytań, a w drugiej kolumnie mamy warunki dotyczące A i B
wymagane, żeby
Alice i Bob wygrali.
W pierwszych trzech przypadkach
iloczyn logiczny A i Y wynosi zero, więc suma modulo 2 musi być równa zero
żeby wygrali,
co jest tym samym, co stwierdzenie, że A i B muszą być równe — bo A i B są bitami — a w czwartym przypadku
iloczyn logiczny X i Y jest równy
jeden i więc suma modulo 2 A i B musi być równa jeden, żeby Alice i Bob wygrali,
co jest tym samym,
co stwierdzenie, że A i B muszą być różne.
Taka jest gra CHSH — możemy teraz myśleć o
różnych możliwych strategiach dla Alice i Boba oraz o tym,
jak dobrze mogą w niej wypaść.
Zacznijmy od myślenia o
strategiach deterministycznych, gdzie odpowiedź A Alice jest funkcją pytania X, które otrzymuje — i
podobnie odpowiedź B Boba
jest funkcją pytania Y, które on otrzymuje.
I jak się okazuje, żadna
strategia deterministyczna nie może wygrywać za każdym razem.
Jednym ze sposobów rozumowania jest
po prostu przejście jeden po jednym przez wszystkie możliwe
strategie deterministyczne i sprawdzenie, że każda z nich przegrywa
co najmniej dla jednej z czterech
możliwych par pytań.
Alice i Bob mają każdy
do wyboru cztery możliwe funkcje — widzieliśmy te
cztery funkcje w lekcji pierwszej, więc jest 16 możliwości do sprawdzenia ogółem.
Innym sposobem na to jest
myślenie o równaniach tutaj na ekranie — myślimy
o strategiach deterministycznych
gdzie A i B są odpowiednio funkcjami
X i Y.
Tak więc na przykład A od zero
reprezentuje odpowiedź Alice, gdy jej pytanie X jest równe zero, a A od jeden reprezentuje odpowiedź Alice
gdy jej pytanie X jest równe jeden.
To są cztery równania,
które muszą być prawdziwe, żeby warunki wygrywające były spełnione w każdym z czterech przypadków.
Na przykład jeśli X jest równe
zero i Y jest równe zero, to suma modulo 2 A
i B musi być równa zero,
natomiast w przypadku gdy X jest równe jeden i Y jest równe jeden,
suma modulo 2 A i B musi być równa jeden.
Jednym ze sposobów, żeby zobaczyć, że nie ma sposobu na wybranie funkcji A i B tak, żeby
te równania były wszystkie prawdziwe, jest po prostu wzięcie sumy modulo 2 wszystkich równań.
Suma modulo 2 dowolnej
wartości binarnej ze sobą jest równa zero — więc wynika z tego, że suma modulo 2
lewych stron
jest równa zero — bo mamy dwa wystąpienia A zero, dwa wystąpienia A jeden,
dwa wystąpienia B zero
i dwa wystąpienia B jeden.
Więc zsumowanie ich wszystkich modulo 2
daje nam ostateczny wynik zero — ale jeśli weźmiemy sumę modulo 2 prawych stron równań,
otrzymujemy jeden, nie zero. Więc cztery równania
nie mogą być wszystkie prawdziwe jednocześnie — co najmniej jedno z nich musi być fałszywe,
co doprowadzi do
przegranej Alice i Boba w co najmniej jednym z czterech przypadków.
I tak wynika, ponieważ sędzia wybiera pytania
równomiernie, że prawdopodobieństwo wygranej Alice i Boba
przy użyciu strategii deterministycznej
wynosi co najwyżej trzy czwarte lub 75%.
To, że Alice i Bob mogą wygrywać z prawdopodobieństwem trzy czwarte, jest całkiem łatwe do zobaczenia
w rzeczywistości — jeśli Alice i Bob oboje odpowiadają zero cały czas na przykład,
będą poprawni trzy
razy na cztery.
Tak więc Alice i Bob nie mogą
wypaść lepiej niż wygrywanie 75% czasu przy użyciu
strategii deterministycznej.
A co ze strategią probabilistyczną?
Cóż, okazuje się, że użycie
strategii probabilistycznej wcale im nie pomoże — bo każda
strategia probabilistyczna
może być alternatywnie traktowana
jako losowy wybór strategii deterministycznej, tak jak probabilistyczne
operacje można traktować
jako losowe wybory
operacji deterministycznych, jak widzieliśmy w pierwszej lekcji.
Średnia nigdy
nie jest większa od maksimum, więc wynika z tego, że strategia probabilistyczna nie daje żadnej przewagi
pod względem wygrywania
nad strategią deterministyczną. Obejmuje to nawet możliwość, że losowe wybory Alice i Boba są skorelowane.
Tak więc konkluzja jest taka, że wygrywanie z prawdopodobieństwem trzy czwarte jest najlepszym, co Alice
i Bob mogą osiągnąć przy użyciu jakiejkolwiek strategii klasycznej,
czy to deterministycznej,
czy probabilistycznej.
Naturalnym pytaniem w tym momencie jest, czy Alice i Bob mogą wypaść lepiej, używając strategii kwantowej,
a w szczególności
czy dzielenie splątanego stanu kwantowego, który mogli przygotować
przed zagraniem, może im pomóc.
Odpowiedź brzmi: tak, może — i to właśnie jest sedno tego przykładu i właśnie dlatego jest tak interesujący.
Zobaczmy dokładnie, jak
Alice i Bob mogą wypaść lepiej w tej grze, używając splątania.
WEBVTT
Pierwszą rzeczą, którą musimy zrobić, jest zdefiniowanie wektora stanu kwantowego Chi
theta dla każdego kąta theta, jak widać tutaj na ekranie.
Zatem Chi theta jest równe
cosinusowi theta razy ket zero plus sinusowi theta razy ket
jeden — i przy okazji,
myślimy tutaj
o kątach w radianach.
Na przykład tutaj jest wektor, który otrzymujemy, gdy theta jest równe pi przez
cztery, czyli 45 stopni.
Cosinus pi przez cztery
i sinus pi przez cztery są obydwa równe jeden przez
pierwiastek z dwóch — więc jest to po prostu inna
nazwa dla stanu plus.
Oto inny przykład, gdy theta jest równe trzy razy pi przez osiem — a na wypadek, gdybyś nie znał sinusa
i cosinusa trzech razy pi przez osiem z głowy,
tutaj jest tabela sinusów i cosinusów, których
faktycznie będziemy potrzebować
przez cały ten przykład
i obejmuje te, których potrzebujemy dla tego konkretnego wektora.
Teraz, jeśli chcemy wziąć iloczyn skalarny między dowolnymi dwoma z tych wektorów
dla kątów, powiedzmy alfa i beta, jest to
proste do zrobienia.
Mamy tylko rzeczywiste
wpisy w tych wektorach, więc nie ma złożonych
sprzężeń, o które trzeba się martwić — i otrzymujemy iloczyn cosinusów
plus iloczyn sinusów, i możemy użyć jednego ze
wzorów na dodawanie kątów
żeby to uprościć — jest to
cosinus różnicy między kątami — i ponieważ funkcja cosinus
jest symetryczna względem zera,
tak naprawdę nie ma znaczenia, w jakiej kolejności je bierzemy.
Jeśli nie masz takich tożsamości trygonometrycznych zapamiętanych,
nawiasem mówiąc, nie jesteś sam — ale nie musisz ich pamiętać,
możesz je po prostu wyszukać. Ta ma jednak sens,
gdy myślisz o geometrycznej interpretacji iloczynu skalarnego
między rzeczywistymi wektorami jednostkowymi jako cosinusie kąta między nimi.
Jeśli obliczymy iloczyn skalarny
iloczynu tensorowego dowolnych dwóch z tych wektorów
ze stanem Phi plus, otrzymamy podobnie wyglądające wyrażenie,
z tą różnicą, że mamy
pierwiastek z dwóch w mianowniku.
To jest pierwszy raz,
kiedy stan Phi plus pojawia się w kontekście
tego przykładu nawiasem mówiąc — i wkrótce zobaczymy dokładnie, dlaczego jesteśmy zainteresowani
tym konkretnym iloczynem skalarnym — ale na chwilę
zauważmy po prostu, że otrzymujemy to samo wyrażenie, które mieliśmy
dla iloczynu skalarnego, podzielone
przez pierwiastek z dwóch — więc możemy uprościć jak poprzednio.
Następnie zdefiniujemy
macierz unitarną U theta dla każdego kąta theta
jak widać tutaj —
nie jest trudno
sprawdzić, że jest to rzeczywiście macierz unitarna.
Kluczową rzeczą, którą musimy
rozpoznać, jest to, że wektor si theta jest ortogonalny do
wektora si theta plus pi przez dwa — i ma to sens,
bo jeśli obracamy o pi przez dwa, czyli 90 stopni, otrzymujemy wektor ortogonalny.
Jeśli następnie przemnożymy U
theta przez U theta dagger, otrzymujemy macierz jednostkową.
Intuicyjnie mówiąc,
to, co ta macierz robi jako operacja, to
mapuje si theta na ket zero i si theta plus pi dwa na ket jeden.
W tym momencie mamy
wszystko, co potrzebujemy, żeby opisać strategię Alice i Boba.
Po pierwsze, tak samo jak w teleportacji i kodowaniu supergęstym, Alice i Bob zaczną od dzielenia e-bitu.
Alice trzyma qubit A,
Bob trzyma qubit B, i razem dwa qubity
są w stanie Phi plus.
Działania Alice są następujące: patrzy na bit X, który
otrzymuje od sędziego,
i jeśli X jest równe zero,
wykonuje U zero na A, co akurat jest tym samym,
co nierobienie niczego, bo U zero jest macierzą jednostkową —
jeśli X jest równe jeden, stosuje U pi przez cztery na A.
Po zastosowaniu jednej
z dwóch operacji mierzy A przy użyciu
standardowego pomiaru bazowego i wysyła jakikolwiek wynik
do sędziego.
Bob robi coś bardzo podobnego — jego qubit nazywa się oczywiście B i otrzymuje Y od
sędziego zamiast X —
ale kluczowa różnica jest taka,
że używa różnych kątów dla swoich operacji unitarnych.
Jeśli Y jest równe zero, stosuje
U pi przez osiem, a jeśli Y jest równe jeden, stosuje U minus pi przez osiem.
Wkrótce zobaczymy, dlaczego te wybory kątów są dobrymi wyborami —
nie jest to wcale oczywiste.
I oto diagram circuit,
który wyraża tę strategię.
Bob jest na górze, a Alice
jest na dole tym razem — oto e-bit, który wchodzi
i to są bramki unitarne,
które Alice i Bob mogą, lecz nie muszą stosować
w zależności od tego, jakie są X i Y.
Dla tej i tej bramki mamy bramki kontrolowane przez bit X lub przez bit Y,
a dla tych dwóch tutaj mamy to, co wygląda trochę jak bramki kontrolowane, z tym że kółko nie jest wypełnione.
Oznacza to,
że jeśli bit kontrolny wynosi zero, bramka jest wykonywana — a jeśli kontrola wynosi
jeden, nic się nie dzieje.
Jest to zatem jak
zwykła bramka kontrolowana, z tą różnicą, że role zera i jedynki dla kontroli są zamienione.
Zatem efektywnie Bob
wykonuje tę bramkę tutaj, jeśli Y jest równe zero, wykonuje tę bramkę tutaj
WEBVTT
jeśli Y jest równe jeden — i podobnie Alice wykonuje tę bramkę tutaj,
jeśli X jest równe zero, i tę bramkę tutaj,
jeśli X jest równe jeden.
To jest zatem strategia Alice i Boba — teraz musimy tylko
ustalić, jak dobrze działa.
Do analizy strategii kwantowej, którą właśnie opisałem, naprawdę potrzebujemy tylko dwóch rzeczy w tym momencie: po pierwsze, macierzy unitarnej U Theta
jak widać tutaj, i
po drugie, tego wzoru.
Tak naprawdę nie potrzebujemy już nawet definicji wektora si theta — te dwa równania są wszystkim, czego potrzebujemy.
Są cztery przypadki
do rozważenia, zaczynając od przypadku pierwszego: X równe
zero i Y równe zero.
Jeśli spojrzymy wstecz na strategię, stwierdzimy, że w tym
przypadku Alice wykonuje U zero na swoim qubit, a Bob wykonuje
U pi przez osiem na swoim qubit.
Pamiętaj, Alice jest na dole
a Bob jest na górze, więc stan, który uzyskują, wygląda tak.
Rozwijając to
zgodnie z definicją U theta, otrzymujemy to
wyrażenie, które widzisz tutaj.
Nie musimy rozwijać
tego dalej, bo mamy drugi
wzór, który nam pomoże.
I jeśli zastosujemy ten wzór
do każdego z czterech wyrazów, otrzymujemy to.
W tym momencie Alice i Bob oboje mierzą — i oto tabela, która
wyjaśnia rozkład wyników.
Bierzemy kwadrat wartości bezwzględnej
współczynników, żeby uzyskać prawdopodobieństwa — co akurat jest
kwadratem współczynników,
bo współczynniki są
wszystkie liczbami rzeczywistymi w tym przypadku.
Jeśli skorzystamy z
wartości sinus i cosinus sprzed chwili w tej lekcji
wraz z pewnymi symetriami, możemy wyrazić te prawdopodobieństwa
jak mamy tutaj
w ostatniej kolumnie.
Teraz tym, na czym nam tak naprawdę zależy,
jest prawdopodobieństwo wygranej — i pamiętaj, że w przypadku gdy X i Y są oba zero,
wygrywają, gdy A i B są równe, a przegrywają, gdy A i B nie są równe.
Obliczając te prawdopodobieństwa, stwierdzimy, że prawdopodobieństwo,
że A i B są równe, jest sumą tej liczby i tej liczby,
co jest równe dwa plus
pierwiastek z dwóch całość przez cztery, czyli około 85%.
Prawdopodobieństwo, że A i B nie są równe, to dwa minus pierwiastek z dwóch całość przez cztery — co jest naturalnie jeden minus ta ilość,
którą właśnie obliczyliśmy — więc
wygrywają z prawdopodobieństwem około 85% w tym przypadku.
Są trzy kolejne przypadki do rozważenia, ale wszystkie są bardzo podobne do tego,
w przypadku X równe
zero i Y równe jeden, Bob stosuje U minus pi przez osiem, zamiast U pi przez osiem,
wartości w
wzorach nieco się zmieniają, ale w końcu otrzymujemy dokładnie
te same prawdopodobieństwa, które mieliśmy w poprzednim przypadku.
Gdy X jest równe zero i Y jest równe jeden, Alice i Bob nadal wygrywają,
gdy A i B są równe — więc mamy dokładnie to samo prawdopodobieństwo wygranej
co poprzednio.
W trzecim przypadku, gdy X jest równe jeden i Y jest równe zero, mamy podobną sytuację — kąty są inne,
ale mają dokładnie
ten sam wzajemny związek,
i w rzeczywistości otrzymujemy dokładnie
ten sam wektor, który uzyskaliśmy w poprzednim przypadku.
Prawdopodobieństwa są zatem takie same i takie samo jest prawdopodobieństwo wygranej.
Ostatni przypadek jest nieco
inny, jak można się spodziewać, bo warunek wygranej
jest w tym przypadku inny.
Gdy X i Y są oba równe jeden, Alice i Bob wygrywają, gdy
A i B są różne.
Podstawowa metoda jest taka sama, choć kąty są inne — tym razem otrzymujemy ten wektor tutaj
i możesz to sprawdzić, przeprowadzając wymagane odejmowania.
Prawdopodobieństwa w końcu się zmieniają — i jeśli sprawdzimy potrzebne wartości, widzimy, że prawdopodobieństwa efektywnie
zamieniły się miejscami w porównaniu z poprzednim przypadkiem — więc tym razem to prawdopodobieństwo,
że A nie jest równe B, jest tym większym z dwóch,
ale to dobrze, bo w tym przypadku Alice i Bob wygrywają,
gdy A i B nie są równe.
I ponownie wygrywają z
prawdopodobieństwem wynoszącym około 85%.
Biorąc pod uwagę, że wygrywają w każdym
przypadku z tym samym prawdopodobieństwem, wynoszącym dwa plus pierwiastek z dwóch całość przez cztery, czyli około 85%,
jest to prawdopodobieństwo,
że wygrywają ogólnie.
To lepiej niż jakakolwiek klasyczna strategia może osiągnąć w tej grze — i właśnie to czyni to interesującym.
To akurat jest
optymalne prawdopodobieństwo wygranej dla jakiejkolwiek strategii kwantowej — nie można wypaść lepiej niż to przy użyciu jakiegokolwiek stanu splątanego.
Ten fakt jest znany jako nierówność Tsirelson — jest nazwana na cześć Borisa
Tsirelson, który jako pierwszy to udowodnił, i o ile wiem, był
jednym z pierwszych,
którzy opisali ten przykład jako grę. Jeśli analiza,
przez którą właśnie przeszliśmy, wydaje się nieco tajemnicza,
można myśleć
o tym geometrycznie — co może pomóc
dać ci lepsze wyczucie dla wyboru kątów.
Konkretnie, jeśli użyjemy
wzoru, który widzisz tutaj, który możemy łatwo wywnioskować
z wyrażeń,
które znaleźliśmy dla
zaangażowanych iloczynów skalarnych, to możemy alternatywnie
wyrazić prawdopodobieństwa różnych możliwych
wyników pomiaru
WEBVTT
w czterech przypadkach w następujący sposób: po pierwsze, jeśli X, Y wynosi zero, zero, to oto prawdopodobieństwa
różnych wyników pomiaru — musisz albo cofnąć się do analizy, którą właśnie przeprowadziliśmy, albo do niej zajrzeć, żeby dojść do tego za pomocą naszego wzoru.
Tutaj możemy zobaczyć
różne wektory stanów narysowane tak jak poprzednio — i kod kolorów jest taki, że niebieski odpowiada
wynikowi zero, a czerwony
odpowiada wynikowi jeden.
Widać, że kąt
między niebieskimi wektorami i kąt między czerwonymi
wektorami jest stosunkowo mały —
wynosi pi przez osiem w obu przypadkach — więc cosinus jest stosunkowo duży, i to oznacza, że prawdopodobieństwo, że dwa wyniki
są równe, jest stosunkowo duże.
W przypadku gdy X, Y wynosi zero, jeden, mamy podobną sytuację — kąty między wektorami tego samego koloru są małe,
więc prawdopodobieństwo
równych wyników jest znowu stosunkowo duże.
Trzeci przypadek jest podobny, a w czwartym przypadku,
gdy X, Y wynosi jeden, jeden, dzieje się coś interesującego — tym razem, po prostu ze względu na sposób,
w jaki te wektory zostały dobrane, widzimy, że kąty między
wektorami tego samego koloru
są stosunkowo duże — a konkretnie kąty wynoszą trzy razy
pi przez osiem w obu przypadkach.
Oznacza to, że prawdopodobieństwo,
że wyniki pomiarów są równe, jest stosunkowo małe — ale jest to jedyny przypadek,
w którym Alice i Bob wygrywają,
gdy ich odpowiedzi się różnią —
więc właśnie o to chodzi.
Jeszcze raz, oto wektory: gdy X, Y wynosi zero, zero,
gdy X, Y wynosi zero, jeden,
gdy X, Y wynosi jeden, zero,
i gdy X, Y wynosi jeden, jeden.
I być może ten geometryczny
obrazek jest pomocny w budowaniu pewnej intuicji
co do tego, jak ta strategia działa
i dlaczego te różne kąty zostały wybrane tak, jak zostały.
Żeby zakończyć lekcję, poczynię kilka krótkich
uwag na temat gry CHSH.
Po pierwsze, jak już wspomniałem, ten przykład nie zawsze
jest opisywany jako gra.
W środowisku fizyków na przykład bardziej powszechne jest
opisywanie tego przykładu po prostu jako eksperymentu, a nie gry —
a Alice i Bob są
traktowani jako detektory, a nie gracze.
Podstawowa idea takiego eksperymentu, gdzie splątanie prowadzi
do wyników statystycznych niezgodnych z
jakimkolwiek klasycznym opisem,
lub ogólniej z jakąkolwiek
teorią opartą na tak zwanych lokalnych zmiennych ukrytych,
wywodzi się od Johna Bella — patrona stanów Bella —
i dlatego ludzie często nazywają
eksperymenty tego rodzaju testami Bella.
Niekiedy mówi się też
o twierdzeniu Bella, które można sformułować na różne sposoby, ale zasadniczo mówi, że mechanika kwantowa
nie jest zgodna z tak zwanymi teoriami lokalnych zmiennych ukrytych.
Gra CHSH, czyli nierówność CHSH, jest zasadniczo bardzo ładnym i przejrzystym
przykładem testu Bella,
i można myśleć o
tym przykładzie jako o dowodzie lub demonstracji twierdzenia Bella.
Druga uwaga jest taka, że gra CHSH daje nam jeden sposób na eksperymentalne sprawdzenie, że teoria informacji kwantowej
jest teorią dokładną. Możemy rzeczywiście przeprowadzać eksperymenty implementujące grę CHSH,
w tym strategię opartą na splątaniu,
którą właśnie opisałem, i sprawdzić, czy działa — i działa.
Daje nam to
wysoki stopień pewności, że splątanie jest realne — i w odróżnieniu od być może
mglistych lub poetyckich sposobów,
w jakie próbujemy znaleźć
wyjaśnienie splątania, gra lub eksperyment CHSH
daje nam konkretny
i sprawdzalny sposób obserwowania splątania.
Jeśli to brzmi ważnie,
to dlatego, że jest — a Nagroda Nobla z fizyki z 2022 roku
docenia właśnie to.
Nagroda została przyznana
Alainowi Aspectowi, Johnowi Clauserowi — który jest C w CHSH — i Antonowi Zeilingerowi
za eksperymenty ze splątanymi fotonami, które ustanowiły naruszenie
nierówności Bella — innymi słowy, które
wykazały, że strategie kwantowe
tego rodzaju, które opisałem, faktycznie działają i przewyższają strategie klasyczne.
I jeśli chcesz dowiedzieć się więcej na ten temat, zachęcam do obejrzenia
wideo o Twierdzeniu Bella autorstwa mojej koleżanki Olivii Lanes,
tu na kanale Qiskit na YouTube.
I wreszcie temat
gier nielokalnych ogólnie jest naprawdę fascynujący — i jest to
aktywny obszar badań,
który łączy
fizykę, informatykę i czystą matematykę — i wciąż jest wiele
interesujących pytań
o gry nielokalne,
które pozostają bez odpowiedzi do dziś.
I to jest koniec lekcji czwartej, a zarazem koniec
pierwszej jednostki serii na temat Podstaw Informacji Kwantowej.
Pierwsza lekcja wyjaśniała,
jak działa informacja kwantowa dla pojedynczych układów w izolacji, a druga lekcja wyjaśniała, jak działa informacja kwantowa
dla wielokrotnych układów —
co dość naturalnie wynika z tego, jak działa dla pojedynczych układów.
WEBVTT
Trzecia lekcja wprowadziła
model quantum circuit obliczeń, a w czwartej lekcji przyjrzeliśmy się trzem ważnym przykładom,
które ilustrują rzeczy, które
możemy zrobić ze splątaniem.
Po drodze zobaczyliśmy kilka bardzo ważnych pojęć matematycznych,
w tym iloczyny tensorowe i iloczyny skalarne, i zaobserwowaliśmy
pewne fundamentalne ograniczenia
informacji kwantowej.
Mam nadzieję, że dołączysz do mnie
w kolejnej jednostce serii, która będzie poświęcona algorytmom kwantowym, gdzie skupimy się na pytaniu,
jakie przewagi obliczeniowe
oferuje informacja kwantowa.
Do zobaczenia.